だねしょうが経験したことあるような場面だと思うんですけども強い人っていうと威厳
のあるような人の大切なものを壊したすごい怖くないですか例を出しましょう例えば
ですが交通室にある付高そうな飾り物をぶっ壊したらねじゃあ強いんですよ
近所にいるのがすごい交差なおじいちゃんの大切にしている盆栽おいしよる
とか誰しもんでたぶんなんとアルバムです強いという家になるような雷おやつとかこう
調節とエラさんの人の大雪が高そうなものをぶっ壊したときの恐怖感っていうのが僕の
今までの経験によると人生で一番強い調教方と思うんですよ今日はその状況がを
作り出してみようと思いますそういう追い込まれた時によってその人の内面的などんな
人間
以下っていうのは分かればもうちょっと見ていこうと思いますそれであげてみましょう
維持もさせたぞ
ああパッと見高級が何ねこの箱を果たし何が入っているのでしょうか
me
そうです超巨大なダイヤ
[音楽]
22たーーーー偽物ですやっぱと見たらそうななマジでこのサイズやばいよもう
めっちゃ出るんですからねマジで高そうに見えますまあ出しちゃうすごい安っぽい
ドッキリ指輪なんですけど jive 初主催ばいいんじゃない
あっ外れた
ずれたらもうソース照明がダイヤ強くで食べられるのかなったとかわかんないすかこれ
5 o 9番からまあ値段にするとだいたい1億2000万円くらい
多分それぐらいの値打ちのサイズでしょダイヤです抹茶偽物鍋やすいんですけどねと
いうわけで今日の動画はこの1億2千万円の推測ですけどこの1億2千万円のダイヤを
今からお野菜
預けますねこれがまあ大谷なものと社長で大家さんがこれをターゲットと僕に紹介し
ます紹介しては高いすごいですねた話を聞いた後に大家さんが家を売ってて出てる間に
あの僕がこれを使って遊んでフッカーしますぶっ壊した時にターゲットの表だがさて
どうするかを楽しいいればいいかこれサシェ
here
大家さんちょっと自慢気にこれをいいだろう
をそれぞれつけたとか
タイの対応いいね海のこの後音ってそうなの
塗ったあった100円っていう
親も的かなぁ冊入って1億2000万円というのを五流しって二人二番してもらって
立つと呼んでまいりますはい
[音楽]
多い
ヤップもうスーツ板についていたなこれから最近パンツに指はホントあのこんにちは
はじめまして
縦メンっていう名前で立てないパターン行くデブなニックネームですね
ず武器でしなくていいっていうかよねっとまでしてるなあこのタイム大抵知ってる
第二の魂のところの骨えええええ
妻のこのお金は貯まる8
すごい
[音楽]
ブーブーぴゅーん
何所よう仕上げねっ
5知らん
[音楽]
うわぁええええやー
ays が刃シャコンヌっていう100万ドル
でどんぐらいだ
五木昶
100100まかける115メートルのか
えっ
数えられられないから1強く1500番がでるかな
5分やっぱいい
a だバイバーイどうぞ
襲われたぞ音大丈夫か処分
プチやセックスするぞやばい強い ua
大きされた珍しいを言って訳じゃないですかいよいよ
すっ守って守ってついてなくないああああそれはですよいいねぇ
ちょっにネーナメっはれっ
てしまうは変わりやがったん
うよすごいローンなのかいましたけどすごいかっていうか買わされたという川崎言え
ねぇ日本に関してくれなかったんじゃないですがいい
強いああそれが僕も年つ集めますか雑にと使ってから3つジョブウォッチいいな
痩せ月謝なくれますしかし今やバッハ
なあ
ここは側だけでも3件ものですねえええええええええ
脇汗がちょっとヤバいよ何
ボブんじゃない
アーサー6じゃんはいじゃんっ
ブーブー言っマスター
もうまず釜谷はせないガールズや映像ですよねっ
[音楽]
ブーブー
バッハどうするどうするでも普通に
をするんだよ本当に右翼なんですけど
うわあああああああああよし守っ
いやほんといいですかはぁ
えっ北
動けないってないですよポンドやは行ってえっ
気付いてないかん
今大丈夫まずは彼になります
傷つ
フィードフィードへの苦情が女子でついていっ
含む持ってくる
た
悪いこともこれぞ解けただけだよ
ん
ポンバシン
すっ
ん
君うっ
ね自爆をしっかり
でしたターンしますか食べました
購入者さん
別についてます普通建設
ブーバー殺す
ais 抑えておりここへ本当に入っちゃうよ
本当に良い欠航が出る曲時間だよ強く2000を叩けることがないと思ったしか
あとゾンビでもっ
それでっでっ
ゆるやっぱやめ飲んでいいんじゃねじゃああーこんなことだけ見たいですよ
でもちょっとこれは14分ああ
いやば残像席で壊れが発回大学患者がきっ
えっおおおおおおすごい狭い
すごいぐ的だこれ良い
でズッキこれじゃあ今度のこれですね2
株で高精度マジですか
でこれん
4 s
th
[音楽]
b 1 a 4
てまいります
なによってですか何やってんすとエッ
まずは多分ないからこれだった封筒がずれるちょっとえっ
a 壊れちゃうけますよまぞい
やばいよやばい本当にやばいこれマジでは一変古屋さんはまだ帰ってこないですよね
ん
でことです激しい強く
いやヤバイよヤバイよ末やばいよ os が壊れないと思ってタッチとかと実験だけ
たらこれね
いますよね混ぜればいい
中で自称万人なんです思うんですか
えっ
[音楽]
グリスもで収拾つかないんで実測量ですね
あーこりゃおっ釣りやばい s さ
[音楽]
ん
主力だったんだよあっちょ上がっいいよいいよ
[拍手]
いやーな感じですねー
おおーー
比例にはれたなぁ
[音楽]
いやいやどうなるだろう
言われるだなぁ
刹那片面が投げちゃって
じゃあ5分
えっ持ったはっはっは
me
うううう
car
あっはぁ
ブーブー
ありがとうございました dj ねこういう言葉で何度もあると優しい人になれるんだ
よ
よかった方じゃ